[Music]
a woman's body found inside a storage
facility in the northwest valley this
investigation is underway near
centennial parkway and durango
joe muller joins us live from there with
what he knows so far joe
we're on centennial parkway just west of
durango metro investigators were out
here for most of the day they just left
about an hour ago here's a look at this
facility now the woman was found dead
inside a unit on the left side of this
driveway just past this gate now police
are looking into how she died and why
she was locked inside
around 6 monday morning police got a
call from a person who found a dead
woman inside the storage unit police
believe the victim in her 50's was
living in the unit with several other
people it was someone who knew the woman
was living there who called police they
say she died either saturday or sunday
las vegas police homicide lieutenant ray
spencer says they are looking through
security footage to see what may have
happened we believe she has been living
in the storage unit for the last several
days we know for a fact that you cannot
close this door and lock her in there
without knowing that she was in there
police are speaking with the person who
was renting that specific unit and they
are looking for the other people who
were living here at some point he says
there was a lot of drug use happening
there as well hope pilgrim lives nearby
i feel really bad for whoever
whoever has to deal with that honestly
because that was somebody's
mother you know daughter
back out here live i did reach out to
cubesmart who owns this to see what is
done to ensure people are not living in
facilities like this a rep told me
online that the gate is monitored with
specific operating hours now i also did
try and get in touch with the local
manager here to get through on the phone
but we're not able to get through to
anybody at this location or other
locations to find out more information
but police still looking for
tips that may help with this
investigation if you know anything
you're asked to call police or
crimestoppers reporting live in the
northwest valley john mohler live local
news